so looking at week one so at least so
far we got four teams playing tonight
two games morning at football but from
what you saw yesterday
who just just forget thursday night okay
so i'm gonna say week one forget
thursday right first sunday
who impressed you the most
a team a team that impressed me the most
pick whatever you want it could be a
team it could be a broadcast it could be
a player it could be a groundskeeper it
could be an official obviously not an
official so whoever you want
i got to go with kyler murray i got to
go with murray to hopkins
because connection huh
yeah well 14 catches for hopkins and
we've all he's been one of those guys
i'm happy for him because he's one he's
been one of those guys who is always who
has gotten some credit for being a great
receiver in in less than ideal
circumstances now he got deshawn watson
who was a great quarterback
but once he gets to sean watson now
the last couple of years we find out he
doesn't have a coat head coach who's all
about him so in this situation he got
his money a record deal in arizona he's
got a young quarterback
yeah he's got a coach
who says okay this is what the offense
this is the offense i'm going to have
i'm really happy for for deandre hopkins
and we talked about him and talked about
murray i don't think a lot of people i
don't know what vegas said because i
didn't bet on that game either mike but
i don't know what vegas said about
niners
cardinals but i'm guessing the niners
were favorites
yeah the cardinals could be at home for
sure yeah
and cardinals could be a nightmare they
they they stood out to me how about you
no and calamari look look really good um
you know running and throwing yo i'ma go
with money making mitch i'm gonna go
with mitchell trubisky
you know and listen i might as well i
didn't see that coming
well of course you didn't because when
they were down 17 who saw who saw them
coming back you know i mean it was look
man you want to talk about the phrase
much maligned
is often used you know what i'm saying
like this guy
has i mean you just mentioned deshaun
watson patrick mahomes two highest-paid
players in history and the bears traded
up to get this guy
and they love him so much in chicago as
an organization that they declined his
fifth year option on the rookie contract
and traded for nick foles that's how
much they believe that mitchell trubisky
is off season put him through a
quarterback
quarterback not controversial
quarterback competition
wins the quarterback competition we were
all like oh he won it okay cool you know
he comes out and i mean he's down every
reason to hang his head and they come
back
i mean that that pass he through to
anthony miller was what that was it was
like that it was like that and so i'm
just like oh okay i see you mr biscuit
so it's like you know what
who knows if this
if it's just you know a one week thing
or if he's actually going to be better
this year but for one week at least
least i want to give this man his his
props you know what i mean good for it's
just one of those feel good story like
good for him you know what i mean he's
taking a lot of time
rightfully so
second overall second number two figure
in the drive trade it up to get it
number two
not only the number two picking the
draft number two picking the same draft
and the sale i'm driving
let me ask you a quick question
and desean watson what's up
let me ask you a quick question
you're wait hold hold on hold on
courtney hold on courtney we go get
there tell them hold up um
who
you're an ohio guy akron ohio yes
shout out suck does it suck more to be a
does it suck more to be a browns or a
lions fan today i've been wanting to ask
you that all morning which which fan
base do you feel sorry for bernie you
know that the browns have not won an
opening since 2004 meanwhile the lions
fired jim caldwell after nine wins and
our man matt patricia got nine wins in
his ten years since like which fan base
right now should just be like you know
what i'm i'm done he ain't my man no
more he don't don't don't don't put that
on me
he don't he ain't returned to
cause the phone still worked he ain't
called nobody ain't called a brother so
no that ain't my boy you get what you
deserve see you caught call somebody
back god um
but no um but i would say who do i feel
sorry for in all seriousness detroit why
dude they haven't won
since the 50s like 1957 was the last
time he won a championship
1957.
so
we talked about we talked about the
browns yeah the browns left and then
came back but detroit can you imagine
just year after year where you're not
angry you're not just angry about the
lions
your daddy angry about the lions your
granddad's angry about the lions because
it has been that long since they won
because on the flip side
because on the flip side i just gave mr
risky props if you're a detroit fan
you're like we just got cooked by
mitchell trubisky it's like it's just
when you think you've seen it all they
just they just invent new and creative
ways to lose speaking of losing before
we move on i just gotta i gotta i gotta
bring up the other team that
quote unquote impressed me although this
wasn't part of the plan
who was my squad going into 2020 i told
you my player was
telling who's been my team going into
2020 who's my team
jacksonville who was my team
jacksonville how did they fool around
and lose that game yesterday how did
jacksonville fool around and lose that
game yesterday
you know what i'm saying
that's not part of the plan that was not
part of what
because michael you and i many moons ago
we were much younger and had more energy
and less obligations
our friendship was forged in franchise
mode and we would turn around franchises
by liquidating the roster in madden
whatever year that would have been two
thousand one two three whatever it was
all of them team we would have picked is
jacksonville the tv we would have picked
to turn around as jacksonville and they
did it for us they literally dismantled
this team they gutted the roster
but who knew that they had heart who
knew that they left this team with some
heart and gardner missed you actually
going 19 for 20 i'm like nah man this is
we take it for trevor what are you doing
hey we
michael no you didn't if we were in
franchise mode michael right now i would
have reset it and simulated it again i
would not have gone with a week one
because that is not we're trying to do
we got 11 draft picks we duval county we
got 11 draft picks and number one draft
pick is supposed to be ours plus the
rams pick that's okay they won they can
win a couple of games not too many but
they're working for us this year listen
i love i like gardner a lot but this is
not part of the plan you can win and get
the picks you can do both no big deal
i want higher picks but those shout out
to 19 out of 20. anytime 20 i don't know
maybe maybe he's not the guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports